[Music]
with one day until chef james and i
battle for the honor of being deemed
yupas i'm off to meet a man
who's famous for three words you don't
normally hear together
smoked fish sausages now sounds a bit
mad doesn't it smoke fish sausage but
if you're a yupa it's a tradition
hopefully it's a secret that i can take
with me to the final cook
well this baby
captain ron what are you doing bud how
are you
where are you oh my goodness me yeah you
want to come see what the youtubers do
captain ron has made fish sausages since
he was a boy
this week is about becoming a yupo yeah
and
they said you've got the best smoked
fish sausage oh yeah anywhere in the uk
yup i put it up against anybody now i
could smell that smoked sausages from
down the road
oh yeah we got a lot of people showing
that up there so this could be a key
ingredient for my final cut yeah
okay yeah okay here we go bud let's go
hello
baby oh my lord stop it that's a trout
that's a weight drop captain ron that's
huge oh yeah
you sure that's trout that's way too
right there
that's incredible have you ever played a
fish a hundred
a thousand times that's okay there's
your good knife right there i got you a
good short one watch out
yes very carefully in you gotta take the
rib bones off
there yeah right there see man
yeah i don't want that going through the
grinder because we don't want to eat it
no we got a big bone narrows here man
you're missing nothing all right there's
no flies
oh no i've been doing it all my life but
my one eye can see better than you
that one eye is a powerful eye i'm
telling you very powerful
fish filleted not there for sure it's
time to start seeing
how the sausage is made okay
now we just got a grinder okay then we
got that
all right now i get in there you
prick i twitter a little bit out of all
the time
turns out i'm not the only potty mouse
chef in this neck of the woods
i'mma clean that too we can't work on a
dirty surface
no all right now we can mix
i got secret ingredients i can't even
tell you i should tell you but i've been
calling you
if i'm going to become a man i need to
know this give me a few secret
ingredients
i got some salt in there so that's not a
secret stole that right now
all spice yeah oh no
ginger no curry powder no
nutmeg yeah there you go so you gotta
give a little oil
i mix it up with a hand well i know i
get something you want do i have a tray
i'm mixing my hand you might have been
picking your ass i don't know we can't
explain that my hands are clean yeah
okay
look at those hands okay it's fine let
it happen absolutely
nutmeg and secret spices added it's time
to start the casing process gotcha yeah
that's probably ready
this is where the magic starts yeah
crank that baby ready
on you're going backwards i'm good holy
now you just went backwards
he's coming down he's coming he's coming
it's coming it's coming let's see
yeah let's see how nasty that's nice see
that's far enough and you tie that yeah
there you go and then tie that nice
yeah casing complete it's time to put
them into
the wood smoker which is filled with
more of captain ron's secret ingredients
now what flavor is this that just came
from ryan's flavor
i'm too afraid to ask what captain ron's
flavoring is
so how long were they spoken there that
was maybe uh like six hours but you i
got something for you in there right now
you got somebody
i got something ready inside there
i know what that's about but yeah you
always get smoking you want to be a
hubert you got to get in there buddy
having been immersed in captain ron's
flavor
whatever that is it's time to taste the
fruits of our labor
i love loyal nate how juicy they are
oh yeah i'll put here on your nuts
it will
that's something good last living see it
won't break apart when you cut
it either cook may i take those three
yes you can
that was incredible yeah they said it
was the best having tasted it now
yeah for me i think it's gonna be a
little secret weapon from finally there
you go
sir okay thank you what a sausage
the spice is perfect but after that
smoke
the flavor and the moisture inside so
it's giving me ideas now i don't think
james will have that
at least final cook
[Music]
want to see more from my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips